president pedro castillo is swearing in
a new cabinet the third in only six
months the latest shake-up comes after
the interior and prime ministers
resigned this week
critics claim castillo only trusts an
inner circle of advisers operating
behind the scenes they're not appointed
ministers
this political crisis shows corruption
former prime minister mirita vasquez
made serious accusations that the
government is not fighting corruption we
have all our presidents questioned and
is generating an enormous mistrust
towards the authorities
most of peru's former presidents are
under investigation for corruption the
last presidential term was marked by a
series of political crisis that left the
south american nation with four
presidents in only five years
the attorney general has denounced
castillo for illegal sponsorship and
influence peddling the farmer and union
leader denies any allegation instead he
said he hasn't been trained to be
president but critics say that is
unacceptable
he should be prepared and especially in
such a dramatic situation with the
health economic and labor crisis
peru has regressed several points in its
poverty rates and this is an element
that is not for experiments we need
clear answers from our rulers
opinion polls say more than 60 percent
of peruvians disapprove of this
government many peruvians say that
castillo has a credibility problem that
he's not qualified for the job and the
country is adrift former prime minister
mirta vazquez says that castillo could
begin solving crucial issues by
surrounding himself with competent
people
the growing discontent appears to be
overshadowing some of his achievements
like the fight against the covet 19
pandemic at least 80 percent of the
target population has been vaccinated at
least
once we should change this man
immediately because he is ruining
everything economically there are no
jobs no sales
he really does not deserve to be there
he is totally incapable he proves it day
by day it's a shame this person is the
head of peru
lawmakers have to decide whether they
will approve the new cabinet but for now
many opponents say they are focusing
instead in paving the way to vacate him
mariana sanchez lima peru